one more
okay one more one more one more just one
more that is until they release the new
one and the inevitable sequel to that
and the third game which is prequel and
the fourth one that has a disappointing
story in a stupid ending so the last one
was less than stellar but I could see
why some people liked it and there are
excuses that can be made for them this
one however
voilá Felicia this is the number I gave
Whitney Chiang how'd you get it ah it's
still better than spider-man 3 that's
not exactly an achievement let me go
ahead and say no I don't like this game
if I haven't made that clear enough
already
but that doesn't mean people who do like
it or wrong you have every right to
disagree with me and think this game is
a masterpiece my opinion isn't law
sheesh guys are so defensive to me this
is where it felt like B NOx was making
this game out of obligation not hashing
the budget was considerably lower and it
was very clearly pushed out onto store
shelves as fast as they could one of the
first things that sticks out is that in
terms of animation voice acting and
design this doesn't feel at all like a
standard triple-a game but instead a
very high budget indie game make sense
that this game would feel rushed and
desperate to Bank on the hype of the
movie which dissipated pretty quickly
after we all actually saw it 2014 was a
bad year for spider-man all around the
new movie series was tanking in one
comic he was possessed by Doc Ock and in
the other he was [ __ ] dead the
cartoon that will forever live in the
shadow of its predecessor was rotting
children's minds and Activision clearly
stopped caring about producing this
series because they found a new
guaranteed moneymaker to milk for
sequels worse than in the 90s where he
was blonde and also a clone but not
actually a clone this game is a product
of the darkest time for the care
nitch shows so with that bleak opening
remarks let's dive in ah [ __ ] I
accidentally stole another red letter
media joke I love that the title screen
has a 50,000 word legal document on it
okay it's Andrew Garfield is face so
they went with the next best thing
model the most generic looking human
being on the face of the earth and have
that one guy voice and this is
apparently enough of a milestone that
they marketed this on the box plays
Peter Parker while you converse with
kingpin Kraven and others holy [ __ ]
somebody called CNN really that's what
you lead with have conversations with
people oh boy I bet this will have some
Mass Effect quality dialog am i right
and what are you finding out that the co
demon knows we played as Peter Parker
before tons of times there's definitely
more interesting they're [ __ ] I hate
this guy I hate his face I hate your
face join the club
his head is too small his character
model sucks what is wrong with you all
they needed to do was swap heads with
the vigilante suit and the proportions
would be fine think smarter not harder
kids well after being a dick to Hurley
from lost Peter thinks wow the sound of
gunfire when I a 15 year old am alone on
the streets at night in a dangerous city
check that out better go investigate
that right away Ben Uncle Ben dies in an
awkwardly animated cutscene and we get
some exposition on spider-man as if we
didn't know who that was already what an
opening the overall story of this game
is kind of a jumbled mess of the movie
it was based on plus some completely
unrelated storyline that they seemed far
more interested in telling I get the
feeling that like with the last game B
NOx
really wanted to have an original story
for this game that explores gaps the
movies left unfilled but someone forced
them to half-ass it into an adaptation
of what is runner-up for the worst
spider-man movie the story is actually a
little better than the last one because
it doesn't jump a million robotic sharks
instead it just tries to explore themes
of morals like if it's right for
daredevil to kill in the name of justice
spider-man I mean spider-man oh I'm so
sorry I got this confused or something
else for a second the story here feels a
lot like they had a better general idea
to run with than last time
but it's executed awkwardly and the
script feels a few drafts away from
being genuinely pretty good all that was
needed was a rewrite to change some
characters around and definitely cut
some of them out because after a while
it stops feeling coherent and becomes
overstuffed with plot lines that all
ultimately have a very bland and
uninteresting conclusion so remember in
the movie where spider-man just gave up
looking for Uncle Ben's killer and the
plot was never resolved well I applaud
this story for trying to figure out a
solution to that mess he goes after him
anyway and just short of catching the
guy and ripping him a new organic
web-shooter hole he's killed off by
someone the media has named the carnage
killer well at least we know what
happened to him I still think the
conclusion was better when it was
revealed he was looking for a
bootleggers secret treasure hidden in
Aunt May's house and he teamed up with
Mysterio to fake her death at an old
folks home now comics are stupid why do
I read this [ __ ] so spider-man goes on a
quest to stop an out-of-control gang war
between rival mobs and also get a chance
to talk with this serial killer who's
been butchering criminals
he's been thinking about going in the
murdering business himself as of late
and could use some advice now the
biggest problem is that they take Cletus
Kasady the guy who may as well be
Charles Manson with superpowers and they
try to make him a violent antihero like
The Punisher or more aptly Dexter some
New Yorkers we spoke to applaud the fact
that violent criminals are being taken
off the streets
hey somebody wants to clean up the trash
I say more power to him holy [ __ ] they
just made him Dexter nice v-neck buddy
that's real threatening I take issue
with this because this is a character
who is known for being a sadistic
psychopath who throws small children out
of ten story windows for fun now the
game tries to ride him into being a
candidate for the story's moral compass
that's a really strange direction to
take with it
no pleat is Cassady is not a
misunderstood hero and the Joker isn't
the protagonist of The Dark Knight I
will not argue morals with this person
stop it and then Kraven is introduced
into the plot too with pretty much the
same twist instead of only hunting
animals Kraven is also some kind of
lethal vigilante in his spare time like
he does it on the weekends I guess he
comes up with this super elaborate plan
to Train spider-man to be a better
vigilante and then kill him
you made him better at his job so you
could kill him
how dense can you be no wonder you lost
idiot
the unforgivable things about the scenes
with Kraven are that they are actually
really interesting this is a great
representation of Kraven the hunter and
it's actually kind of cool to just look
around his house and talk about his take
on life in the law through hunters wish
to conserve the natural world it is
where we find the beasts I almost wish
they hadn't pulled this stupid twist
where he backstab spider-man we would
have improved this story if Peters
screwed up and let something bad happen
then Kraven blamed him for letting an
innocent get hurt and decided to go
after him for his recklessness anything
is better than oh by the way I'm gonna
kill you now in the park for no reason
oh hey is this a crime scene can I see
am i disturbing you guys the rest this
story outside
even and cassadee is far less
interesting and it's also pretty
unimportant as it feels like everything
else is shoehorned into Pat out the
length of the game it reminds me a lot
of earlier spider-man games were side
stories with villains that don't have
any effect on the main plot will crop up
and serve as boss battles though I feel
like we've got to the point that this is
a step down from the writing we know
these games are capable of having
there's plenty of scenes devoted to try
and use kingpin as an antagonist and
they also rip off dialogue from The
Ultimate Comics during his boss fight
you are so bad cut yourself shaving
marshmallow fluff comes out you're so
fat your high school taken from a
helicopter I'm all for using source
material but the delivery these lines is
so distractingly bad that it kills all
tension you're so fat I could have you
arrested for 10
by which I mean buttcrack just be clear
honestly Vincent D'Onofrio ruined
kingpin for me he did this by being the
best kingpin and all other renditions of
the character even in the source
material sometimes feel cartoonish and
flat by comparison so now this bloated 9
foot tall super villain with a silly
voice is made even more insufferable
kingpin serves is pretty much the only
line connecting all these totally
unrelated plots and it's weird when the
game suddenly forgets about him
considering them made him the center of
attention until about the 80% mark then
we get God Harry Osborn is that really
you does it look like me no Harry Osborn
is dead thanks to you all that's left is
the gap oh well at least you tried and
then of course Green Goblin and electro
are shoved in his side characters that
you don't even really care about or do
they fit in with the overall themes of
this story they're just there for the
sake of staying synched with the movie's
plot but Gwen isn't for some reason it's
odd that she was omitted from the story
considering how she was so central to
the last game and even more so to the
plot of the second movie whatever who
cares about consistency what's the point
of saving the world Wednesday she's not
hello darkness while
speaking of consistency the gameplay is
very similar to the last one with some
tweaks of course some work and some
don't but overall I think I'd say this
one plays a little better
the swinging is far from perfect but
it's the best it has been since say web
of shadows though it definitely doesn't
surpass that game it's unique in the
fact that the left and right triggers
shoot web line from each corresponding
hand on Sergeant William James over here
and it feels way better than the last
game you swing at a much slower pace and
the webs are back to attaching
relatively close to physical objects
again so now Spider Man feels like he
has more weight applied doing the last
game was about making the swinging look
cool but this one tried making it feel
cool and even though you really don't
have much momentum and you could
probably get everywhere faster with the
web rush this swinging does its job
without being annoying or broken that's
all I want I don't want it to be
annoying or broken I just wish it was
designed so you had to remember to send
out a web line from the correct side to
catch yourself because even if there
isn't a building near him he swings just
fine and even still there isn't much of
a danger because there isn't any fall
damage I personally think it would be
much more exciting if splattering on the
concrete was a concern quick insomniac
grab a pen and paper this is important
fall damage adds tension and incentive
to get better at swinging put that in
there okay you got it alright great the
speed and physics for the swinging are
fairly realistic and it's honestly fun
to use but it's not very memorable and
it certainly could have been better in
the future let's spice it up and go back
to the days of Spider Man being a
bombastic human pendulum that loops
around lampposts and kicks people
it's more fun that way a good swinging
mechanic should be more rewarding to the
player than this you'd have more of a
learning curve and give the player a
more room to discover and evolve you
start out using it as a means to get
from point A to B but at the end of the
game you should be using it to do all
kinds of amazing tricks that you learn
because your friend from work told you
about it the game didn't have to hold
your hand in fact if the swinging is
designed well all these cool animations
you do with Web Rush mode you should be
able to know how to do these manually
it's so much more engaging than just
tapping one button and watching him go
Tommy okay we're still doing the notes
thing please remember this okay check
this out I call it the inverted tea bag
the fighting mechanics are pretty much
the same as the last game even keeping
the environmental objects that you pull
an instant win if you use them you want
to grab that upgrade as fast as possible
although these environmental takedowns
aren't nearly as common as sometimes
feel like they forgot to add some to
certain flight locations the best way to
do the combat efficiently is to focus on
one guy at a time and just counter
everyone else while you keep going after
that enemy then move on to the next one
I once got a really angry comment about
how spider-man 3 in this game both have
great combat and aren't designed for
casuals and boy was that person right
you know what let's load up the
challenge arena and test how intuitive
this design is all right you're ready
folks the objective is to survive all
the waves of enemies without getting hit
more than five times so that's pretty
tough right alright let's give it a shot
Oh
it's real difficult it isn't challenging
and after a while it isn't even very
exciting upon looking at this combat
style at the end I think there needs to
be a middle ground with spider-man's
fighting ability not too cartoonish but
not too realistic either because they
both get pretty boring after too long I
think the perfect spider-man fight
mechanic should be like a cross between
Ultimates visceral and acrobatic melee
moveset spider-man to spider sense dodge
and web of shadows web strikes the
punches feel powerful and painful you
can dodge an enemy's attacks and fluid
motions and you can take the fight to
the skies and combine movement with the
attacks it saw me act seriously there's
going to be a quiz on this later for the
love of God write this down
I'd say the most fun I had was during
the stealth segments there were just the
right level of challenge and added extra
reason not to get seen because it puts
you one step closer to losing the
objective you got to really take your
time and watch the enemy patterns I
guess I liked it because it requires a
little more forward thinking than the
rest of the combat and it's satisfying
to make it through a section without
getting spotted although on multiple
occasions I found a bug where everyone
in the map is aware of you at all times
right at the beginning of the level and
you can't hide so it fails you
automatically [ __ ] I love when the game
punishes you for its flaws it's the best
wait that's the sound barrier thing from
web of shadows except it hurts me now so
this is what it's like
I'm the symbiotes now
huh well I guess I learned a lot today
about interspecies segregation those
aliens didn't want to take over our
society and use our bodies as meat
puppets they just wanted a home
I also learned you can climb your web
and I feel like a huge idiot for not
knowing this until a flood of comments
told me about it I guess it's a nice
addition to have a health bar again I
don't know why they would have taken
that out considering it so useful your
last game getting hit either felt
inconsequential or devastating because
you had no gauge of the amount of damage
other than the screen turning all hazy
and red at which point you just felt
like you were about to die so you just
swing off and wait until it went back to
normal
it totally killed the flow of combat now
in this one when your health gets low
you can swing away and manually heal
yourself and it totally kills the flow
of combat and during boss fights it's
[ __ ] impossible to find time to do it
ah one step forward two steps back come
on guys
what are all you tough guys so afraid of
the carnage killer he's murdering my
people huh it into the Russians
hammerheads crew mr. negatives man
everyone thinks the other guys are
paying him I'm starting to worry you
some kind of freak like that giant
lizard a while back or that dude with
all the other robots
so as long as he's out there killing the
gang war goes on and it gets worse I
just feel like they barely learn
anything from the lukewarm response to
the last game I was really hoping they'd
improve the boss fights but those are
just as underwhelming too though they're
thankfully with actual characters again
instead of lame-ass robots let's take
the fight with shocker for example
that's a really cool rendition of his
costume and he looks badass but the
fight is so formulaic and it feels like
it's just there to burn up time you zip
over to him wail on him for a second he
does an area of effect move you jump out
of the way then you zip over and start
hitting him again there's no strategy
and it feels like you can't do anything
to pose a genuine threat all the bosses
are like this use these stupid shotgun
plaits on kingpin run over smack him
around dodge back rinse repeat
punch Kraven then use the web strike on
then punch him and web strike they're
all about repeating a very simple
pattern I mean he comes out of
absolutely nowhere in the story but at
least the boss with electro looks really
cool it's nice to finally have one of
these take place in the open world map
Plus this one is actually kind of
challenging you know what this one's
okay electro doesn't look too great and
this is the most generic looking rooftop
I've ever fought someone on what electro
is hard to make into a boring vilasa
fight the boss with Harry is weird
because it's like a combination of the
fight from the ps2 version of spider-man
3 and the Goblin boss from friend-or-foe
of all the sources of inspiration to
take from the previous games those were
not the ones to use